يعلن رسميا اليوم في مقر حلف شمال الاطلسي
في بروكسل انضمامه فنلندا الى الحنف الى
الحلف لتصبح بذلك العضو الحادي والثلاثين
في المنظومه العسكريه الغربيه وكان الامين
العام لنيتو يانبرد قد اكد ان هذا اليوم
سيكون تاريخيا بالاعلان الرسمي عن انضمام
فنلندا للحلف ورفع عالمها رسميا مشددا على
ان هذا الانضمام سيعزز ان فنلندا وقوه
وترتبط فنلندا بحدود بريه مع روسيا تمتد
لمسافه 1300 كم يعني مضاعفه طول الحدود
المشتركه للحلف مع روسيا كانت اخر عقبه في
طريق عضويه فنلندا ازيحت الاسبوع الماضي
بعد ان صدق البرلمان التركي على طلبه
السينكي لكنه ابقى طلب السويد معلقا بسبب
اتهامات تركيه
في اشاره الى حزب العمال الكردستاني
وتواجه السويد ايضا اعتراضات مجانيه بعد
انتقاد ات وجهاتها الى رئيس الوزراء
المجري بشان احترام القيم الديمقراطيه